metro says an off-duty north las vegas  police officer shot and killed his  daughter before killing himself this  happened this morning near lake mead and  mlk according to police the suspect was  arguing with his wife when he pulled out  a gun they say the woman and the  couple's teenage son were both shot  during the struggle they were hurt but  escaped to call for help the mother and  the son then fled from the residence  to the nearby neighbor's house and the  female was stating that her husband was  currently inside the house and tried to  kill her  metro says the officer then shot and  killed his daughter before taking his  own life identities have not been  released